this is a production of Cornell
University
so Gus thank you and I'd like to thank
the folks in plant biology at Cornell
University for allowing me to do this
seminar tell you something that's been a
passion in my life for the last 35 36
years and also to come back to Cornell
which is one of my most favorite places
in the world to be my time as a postdoc
here was really really wonderful so
every decade or so I come back and it's
really quite nice but what I'd like to
do today is start you off sort of with a
very big global perspective if you were
on a spaceship and you were coming to
the planet Earth the color that you
would see on the planet would be blue
primarily from all the aquatic
environments on the planet but let's get
rid of them and if we were to look at
the land masses the other color that
would be pretty obvious is that of green
and that of course comes from the
pigments that you get from the great
diversity of land plants that occupy
many many many terrestrial ecosystems on
the planet so the big question as in
intriguing plant biologists for a long
time has been where did land plants come
from from what group of organisms did
they come from
so if you went back about 450 million
years 500 million years this is what
eukaryotic plant life might look like it
would be green algae living probably in
a thermal outflow of a shallow wetland
area kind of like what you would see if
you went to Yellowstone National Park
and moved away from the real areal hot
springs
so about 450 million years ago we went
from this up to this over here
and the group of organisms that we've
come to know as the ancestors of land
plants and those most closely related to
land plants are called the Kyra fights
or the more proper taxonomic designation
would be the strep the fights the basal
strep device and you undoubtedly have
seen them if you've gone to any aquatic
ecosystem freshwater algae for the most
part but a unique group of of algae not
the biggest group within the green algae
so what I wanted to do just spend a
minute and talk a little bit about the
history of the discovery of Kara fights
as being land plant ancestors and it
really
hasn't been all that long ago that there
are other ideas as to where land plants
and the whole idea of multicellularity
came from if you got to a point let's
say before the 1960s you would see many
different phylogenetic schemes and one
of the more common ones is it gets
something like climate a mones as a
basal organism and then you would have
colonial green algae that swim that
don't swim then you get to filamentous
organisms and then branch filaments and
then Frank amidst issue and then there
you go
and the story there's the land plants
okay so at that time please remember
that the technology that was available
for people to come up to interpret what
might be happening out there was
somewhat limited based on reproductive
biology some basic microscopy and really
that was about it well something
happened in the 1960s that really
changed the whole equation just like
many of the new techniques and protocols
and instruments that we have a molecular
biology today in the 1960s and Beyond it
was the electron microscope that changed
things and in the 1960s people started
using glutaraldehyde as primary fixative
or preparing things for TEM and you got
superior fixation so I just want to
introduce you to some of the great
characters in the history of camera
fights so I've called this the modern
era from about the 1960s until today one
of the Keith pioneers was an Australian
scientist by the name of Jeremy Pickett
heaps and Jeremy Pickett heaps was at
the University of Colorado for a long
period of time and he was a meticulous
microspace a great guy and Jeremy was a
good light microscopy this he would take
his different green algae and he would
spend hours just positioning him just
right on the light microscope to see for
example cell division events to take a
look at reproductive cells um a variety
of different things but he was also an
outstanding electron microscopy he was
able to pinpoint specific processes
using thin section TEM and if you were
to go down probably to man library you'd
probably find this book from 1975 which
he was an amazing book it had a lot of
his micrographs and he was able from
about 1972 to 1975 in a series of
publications to define this group of
algae known as the ko fights there were
different names at the time but he was
one of the first people to champion the
idea of ko fights as land plant
ancestors using ultra structural work
then we had other workers we had Carl
Maddox and Ken Stewart from Miami
University those are my major professors
who about a decade later came up with a
really nice paper in 1984 giving more
definition to the Cairo fights and then
Linda Graham ma2 University of Wisconsin
who worked on a very famous ko fight
Colio kitty and was looking at the
pattern formation in the formation of
parenchymal tissue or the crank
Mississippi white material there and
since the 1980s we've also had a large
group of molecular pioneers that have
come in and interestingly enough a lot
of the molecular data that has been used
to look at the Kara bites really kind of
confirms what people like ticket heaps
and others were able to come up with
with the electron microscope so very
interesting history and it was in the
70s and 80s really where a lot of this
started to blossom alright so here's the
green algae so in this big room known as
the green algae most of the green algae
are not Kara fights they belong to a
group that will call the chlorophyta and
within the chlorophyll you have things
like your seaweeds the former all the
heights there now in this group you have
some freshwater filamentous forms you
have the lichen algae climate omona
spits in this particular group but
probably the largest and most diverse
group that you have are these things
they are designated in the presenta
fight and these are as Carl Maddox my
major professor once said little round
green things that swim or don't swim and
you really got to believe that because
these are really tiny organism Pico
plankton found in the oceans some of the
cells may be only a micron or two in
size they're the most abundant
eukaryotes on the planet they would fit
into this group but then we come to
Strep the fights or the Kara fights and
it really is a group of strange
bedfellows that you find in this
particular group the morphology is very
very different okay you'll see in just a
second that the different forms that you
find there are quite unique so let's
take a look at the Cairo fights really
quickly and if we were to look at the ex
thought Kara fights that are out there
there's basically two groups
there's the early divergent taxa and
within this group we have an organism
name is the stigma it's little round
green thing that looks like the
flattened lifeboat swims around and for
all of you who are interested in other
parts of biology this organism produces
beautiful layers of scales and this was
one of the organism along with some of
its cousins that kindly start to put an
end to how a Golgi apparatus how the
Golgi body works where in effect you do
have the sister neova Golgi actually
move through from the sista trans face
you can see the scales actually forming
as opposed to just stationary sister nee
and you have vesicles taking things from
sister Ana to cisterna chloric ibis and
a new law and rarely found terrestrial
organism if anybody would like to talk
about this later I'd love to talk about
Clark ibis especially if you're
interested in the evolution of
hydrolyzable tannins unique organism
clubs or medium an organism whose genome
is the first of the kara fights to be
sequenced this is an organism that you
find in many terrestrial and semi
aquatic areas if you walk through the
desert Southwest and you're walking at
certain times of the year you're in the
desert you're not walking on sand
they're sander but you hear crunch
crunch crunch those are films of clubs
or midium but most people who are
interested in the evolution of land
plants or looking at the lake divergent
taxa so we have things like Keira and
night Ella that you may have seen Colio
kitty many species formed as purring
them dislike tissue like hey kind of
looks like the liver work so this would
be a good candidate has been a popular
and it for what's the closest living
ancestors to land plants and then we
have the
educating green algae things like
Desmond's and filamentous forms
spirogyra Moogie osha you probably have
seen them alright so here we go here are
the Cairo fights and here are the
different groups and up until about five
or ten years ago there was a question
which of the late divergent forms was
the most closely related to land plants
okay so I come from Saratoga Springs New
York and we just finished the racing
season so it was kind of like a horse
race at the time and that is well maybe
it's going to be something like Kara
okay because yeah it's macroscopic looks
like it has higher plant tissue has
these worlds but it's basically an
aggregation of filaments but its
reproductive structures look like a the
land plant so maybe then there's the
co-opt
okay so the Kaleo detailees well some
species have perimeters tissue they have
antheridia like male reproductive
structures and ago neom the zygotes
retained on the plant so hey there we go
this has got to be the hands-on favorite
and then there is these freaky zig named
italian organisms the ones that
conjugate you know no modal cells got to
worry about sperm cells or excels
unicellular some filamentous forms so in
the early part of this decade there was
some molecular work that was being done
and what they found out as they were
looking at who was going to win this
horse race it was a zig nematodes
alright so it's the conjugating green
algae that turn out to be the closest
living ancestors to land plants and one
of the organisms that i'm going to spend
quite a bit of time on today
that's pentium and pentium is a very
simple organism as you will see and
pentium along with spirogyra are
believed to be organisms that represent
things that are closest to land plants
now i truly understand that the survey
the that has been done looking at the
file economics of all this has been
really limited but until they do more of
a survey that's all the NSF needs to
know alright so now let's just take a
look at
her fights that have been used as model
organisms now terrified say in my title
the word secret well they haven't been
all that secret we've used camera fights
as model organisms for many different
biological applications for example
camera and Nutella are well known for
studies of cytoplasmic streaming you
have people in this audience who have
worked on camera and Nutella and
cytoplasmic streaming it's a wonderful
organism for studying gravitropism and
state'll it's it's an organism that has
been in space regular of whether it's
real space or whether it was simulated
space right you have coeliac ET that has
been used as a model for looking at
pattern development patterns in tissue
development you have organisms like the
Desmond's they have this beautiful form
that have been used in cell
morphogenesis and symmetry getting
particular morphic genetic patterns in
cells and recently there's been some
great stuff we're looking at cell wall
polymers hormone physiology signaling
systems that are indicating a camera
fights might be really nice organisms
for studying some basic facts about
plant biology so for me
I've been working on camera fights for a
long period of time and about 15 years
ago I got interested in the tremendous
amount of polysaccharides produced by
terra fights that are found in shallow
aquatic ecosystems in the Northeast I
spend most of my time from about 5:30
every morning till 9 out in the field
collecting various Kara fights and
trying to get some of the
polysaccharides off in characterizing
them and I must admit this was a
wonderful experience for many many years
not only because you're able to go out
to some really beautiful places but I
had one of the best laboratory
collaborators one of the best laboratory
managers if you like something that was
he was meticulous always kept things
organized and made this laboratory
perfect almost every day and it loops
and it was this guy right over here I be
versed unbelievable they you know they
do not leave any stick you know out of
place and all you have to do is feed
them sticks along have juicy bark
they'll work for whatever
all right so I was interested in these
blooms and some of the mass amounts of
polysaccharide that are pushed out by
these organisms when they bloom
so with these organisms I am working
with these organisms
I found alga sac excuse me a pachyderm
Desmet a unicellular one known as penny
a Margaret aciem this organism was
perfect for a lot of studies looking at
cell walls and secretion as you will see
one of the main reasons for this is that
it's as a very simple morphology its
elongated cylinder with rounded holes
it's a typical Desmet it follows the job
description of a desmond it has two semi
cells surrounding the central zone but
there are a lot of other features that
you'll see that make pentium kind of a
wonderful organism first of all it
produces only a primary cell wall you'll
have to worry about secondary cell walls
complicating issues plus it produces
these unique extracellular gels live
cells can be labeled with a variety of
probes including monoclonal antibodies
and then you could place the cells back
into culture and you can watch
development you can watch expansive
dynamics it's easy to grow and to
manipulate it accommodates rapid micro
array of screening if you want to apply
specific inhibitors and see what happens
to secretory events and it has an
Olympic membrane network that I'm gonna
finish up on that I'd like to show you
it's this is a lean mean secretory
machine and I think it's going to be a
great organism for understanding
secretory dynamics and plants so what
I've been doing over the last ten years
is looking at the cell biology opinion
especially expansion dynamics and
membrane trafficking extracellular
wycombe I've also looked at stress
biology in fact that's what Goss even
and I are been working on is a stress
biology project sponsored by NSF so I
just want to give you three different
facets of some of the work that's been
done with pen yawns these gonna go has
come like categories that you find on
Jeopardy Alex I'd like number one the
real world the most verified so I
listened to your microbiologist
I want to talk to you a little bit about
the unique cell wall where the expansion
mechanism is an easy thing to see Plus
there's something I would call a sticky
business and then the third area is
membrane trafficking on a superhighway
and you'll get to see what secretion
dynamics are really like with this
unicellular organism so I'd like to
start off with the real world of
mosquera flights listen to your
microbiologist and what I mean by that
is we have to recognize that Kara fights
and these land plant ancestors lived in
semi aquatic ecosystems and from an
evolutionary standpoint and from where
they are today there are some unique
mechanisms that they use in order to
survive in these habitats that could be
drying out salt content can go up and
I'm using this quote by a very famous
microbiologist William Costigan who
about 15 years ago in the preface of a
book basically said the vast majority of
microbial life on this planet doesn't
reside in suspensions but lives in
highly complex communities that are
attached to surfaces and what cos
certain was talking about was that of a
biofilm
when we think about these small
terabytes they especially does igni
metallian terabytes there's for the most
part they're stuck to things and the
thing that they're stuck to can very
oftentimes it's a solid object but
cosmic 10 also said that the interface
between water and air constitutes a
surface for the formation of many
biofilms biofilms have been studied
primarily in bacteria and if you look at
them one of the things that you will
notice is that they have a very distinct
structure they're not just simple
colonies of bacteria are covered in
slime they have in these colonies they
have channels they have specific places
where you have different microorganisms
that might be in some kind of symbiotic
relationship appearing but the key thing
is one of the key components of the
biofilm is a polysaccharide or
proteoglycan sheath that is produced in
law
amounts that forms these unique habitats
and I will tell you that Desmond's and
many of the Karaites including pentium
are organisms that produce extensive EPS
states how much
how about microgram quantities per cell
this is in laboratory culture so once
again it's cheating a little bit but
they produce enormous amounts of
polysaccharides it's a something that
seems to be a major mechanism for these
organism survival alright so let's take
a look at the EPS you can look at these
with antibodies raised against the EPS
and this is a cell that had the EPS
washed out and labeled it with its anti
EPS antibody after the cell was kept in
culture for maybe an hour or so so it's
producing incredible amounts of this
polysaccharide okay you could study
these things also by using fluorescent
beads we can look at the production
rates of EPS by taking fluorescent beads
incubating are taking the cells and
incubating in them and walk how these
fluorescent beads are pushed out now
what does pen IAM and what do these EPS
compounds do for Desmond's and some of
the other ko fights they use it for
gliding that is they secrete the
polysaccharide from one area of the cell
it's very hygroscopic so when it comes
out of the backside of the cell it
swells with water and that propels the
organism in a particular direction but
more importantly it's used for
achievement on a surface and performing
biofilms Linda Graham who I told you
about just a few minutes ago she spent
some time in the late 1990s and early
2000s looking at some of the bacteria
found in the EPS biofilm feats of some
Kara fights and it was a unique
assortment of nitrogen-fixing bacteria
sulfate-reducing bacteria that there
really were true biofilm communities
associated with these on EPS sheets that
you find with things like titanium also
just keep in mind as you'll get the
scene a little bit that there's
site-specific secretion
okay that is when they make contact with
a surface and they want to secrete ups
they do it in particular parts of the
cell so what is this stuff well I know
it's a Friday afternoon and I'm not
going to go into detail but um what the
EPS is is a very complex polysaccharide
or excuse me or aggregation of
polysaccharides and it's very very
unique it's not a black uronic acid it's
not a galactic acid um based
polysaccharide it's a glucuronic acid
based polysaccharide with lots of lots
of xylose and chuco's and we've done a
little bit of work on the composition on
under high light conditions and their
high temperature conditions and the one
particular condition that really changes
the EPS is that of high temperature
where we lose uronic acids we have a
decrease in a couple of the main sugars
three lengths yukos and 3/4 length gram
those and terminal galactose residues go
down so there are changes in the
polysaccharide composition under this
stress so one of the things we're doing
right now is taking a look at the EPS in
its secretion under various stress
conditions alright the second thing I
want to talk about is that of the cell
wall once again it only has this
organism only has a primary cell wall
and the expansion dynamics can be
studied quite easily just to review for
you the primary cell wall cell wall that
is produced when an organism is
expanding remember we have cellulose
which is the load-bearing component of
the cell wall we have cross-linking Hemi
cellulose --is and and pectins in
pentium the thing that sort of hits your
right between the eyes are the pectins
because it has it advertised on its
surface pectins are polymers of galaki
Roenick acid and other sugars and this
picture is a little bit complicated but
you could have
several different types of pectin
subdomains you could have pectin just
made up of galactic acid and those would
be the home of galaki Ronan's and then
you could come to some of the most
complicated biopolymers on the planet
things called the RAM the galactose and
in particular Ram no galaki ronan one on
the side chains are extremely extremely
diverse and they can get a very very
complex or polysaccharide to study so we
were interested in the smooth pectin the
Homa galacto Ronan's that don't have any
side chains and RG one or an electronic
like your own n1 and that's the hairy
pectin and it's primarily because it has
these side chains
alright so with pentium hey what did we
find
well along with co-workers at the
University of Copenhagen we looked at
isolated cell walls and looked at the
chemical composition and then some
carbohydrate microarray analysis using a
variety of different monoclonal
antibodies was used so here we have
pentium cell walls that were basically
separated into a CD ta a pectin fraction
then an MeOH or more heavy cellulosic
fraction and then a dachshund fraction
and what we find in Pentium is that we
have the pectins
we have homo galaki Ronan and we have
our key one we have cellulose we have
Arab no black down proteins and I really
don't have time to talk about nor can I
tell you much about some of the other
polymers but in many ways similar to
what you find in land plants we did a
similar study on at the University of
Georgia the complex carbohydrate
Research Center and what you find are
once again your Peck dens and then a
whole bunch of a rabbit ogle act and
something or others whether you belong
to our g1 or a GPS it's a big mystery in
actually many areas of cell wall biology
so what does the Pentium cell wall look
like well you can get cell walls off
Pentium quite easily and that's by
sonicated
okay you don't have to do complex
extractions you just grow the cells up
put them on ice put
little bit of detergent into a buffer
and sonic ate them and this is what you
get and the thing that is most
outstanding represented by this inner
circle over here is what we call the
pectin lattice this is homo galaki ronan
that is complex with calcium to form a
very distinct lattice okay it's a series
of very thick and Phi rolls some of them
are branched they come together and they
terminate outwards or if you were let's
say microorganism landing on the Pentium
surface and you wanted to get a side
view this is what it would probably look
like you could then use a little bit of
ki later and you can remove some of the
calcium and what you can see hopefully
are literally thousands of fibrils about
one to two nanometers in thickness are
probably the homo goal actor Onan that
has complex the calcium all right and
then from a team standpoint this is what
the wall looks like here's that Homa
black Llorona and lattice and what
happens is is that it enters into the
inner wall they are made up of cellulose
in this zone right over here these
little sort of indentations that you see
that are semi electron dense that's
called the medial layer so we have a
pectin outer wall smooth pectin outer
wall or home Agalloch your own an acid
outer wall and then we have this medial
there and then a cellulose inner layer
if we do some immuno labeling we can use
a monoclonal antibody called Jim 5 that
goes after relatively low esterified
pectin some of the lack your own in and
it is located here in the lattice and
also in this medial layer if you use
antibody that goes after the backbone
not two side chains but the backbone of
our g1 what you will find is that it is
only found in this medial layer so right
now this is my model nobody else is in
you'll have to forgive me I'm not an
artist though you might think I am all
right so here we have cellulose forming
the basis of the wall and then here we
have the home of the like your own ants
coming out and then the RG one is
think that's anchoring the home of the
lackey ronin it's probably looking at
some monster pecten domain which has
been recently described by Lita and
Deborah moanin at the University of
Georgia where we're not really dealing
with separate polymers we're just
looking at different geographic domains
pectins pectins are really complicated
and just to speculate a little bit it
may be that the RG one the black
component here is the thing that's
actually interacting with cellulose and
more and more evidence suggests that
pectins are more important than maybe
some of the classic hemicelluloses in
the way a cell wall expands all right so
then I just want to let you know that
the Houma galacto Ronin can be a label
using fluorescent probes and you can
then study subsequent pectin secretion
dynamics you can study expansion
dynamics so I just want to point out one
quick thing so here's Jim 5 and Jim 5
has been a very good antibody for
labeling pentium you could label it put
the cells back into culture and then
you'll the zone here in the middle um is
going to be where new wall material is
produced and if you look at the zone
you'll see this is the lattice this is
what it looks like but I just want to
spend a minute and tell you about some
new valuable probes that are used for
studying pectins in plant cells and
they're really remarkable so if you can
just remember what those teeth excuse me
those SEM images of what the lattice
looked like and then take a look at
something like this ok this is one of
the new probes used for labeling pectins
and what makes this really nice is that
you can actually see some of those
thickened fibers coming up to the point
far more detailed than we got using the
antibodies these probes that I'm going
to describe to you are wonderful because
they're small molecular weight much
smaller than using antibodies and they
can penetrate deeply into the cell wall
and provide you with a lot of wonderful
detail all right so what are these
probes okay oh I can give you this
wonderful detail well one of them is
called the reciprocal
oligosaccharide Pro and I must tell you
it's really easy and these were
developed by a person named Joseph Robin
at the University of Copenhagen and
here's the way it works all right here's
a typical home on the lackey ronan
here's the galaki Roenick acids that are
lined up and these blue dots over here
to represent the methyl groups that are
attached to the carboxylic acid group
that you typically find in pectins that
have not yet been secreted it makes
sense to in effect neutralize the
negative charges on the carboxylic acid
groups because the pectin would be too
sticky and stick into vesicles so most
pectins are produced or methyl e2 the
Houma Galecki Ronin the electronic acid
residues are methylated well typically
what happens in the development of
pectins when it's secreted is they get
the esterified daredi esterified by an
enzyme well known as I'm known as pectin
methyl esters Walt mentioned that in
just a minute but what you do is you
remove the methyl groups and here is and
here are your negatively charged to the
electronic acids well wouldn't it be a
great idea to get something that is
roughly the same size as this that might
have positive charge that you can match
up and you can you could take chitin
orchitis in fragments and what you can
do is add them to pectins
and you can get the kinase in fragments
that at different levels of
polymerization and they'll match up with
the pectin with the Houma galacto Ronin
what you can do is you can add a tag a
fluorescent tag a goal tag and that's
where you get some really really
beautiful pictures one of the new probes
being used these reciprocal
oligosaccharide probes in this case one
called cos um is where you are binding
positively charged amino groups on
Qaida's needles little saccharides with
that of the carbon carboxylic acid
groups on the oligo Galacta or nights a
wonderful type of label there's another
one it's even easier
these are illegal galactic acid probes
and this picture is a little difficult
to discern but the blue little squiggles
that's the home of galaki ronan and the
little yellow dots in there that's
calcium so you have after it's in D
esterified and what will happen is you
have calcium coming in and it will form
these links and that's where you get
something like the lattice that you see
in Pentium all right well the brilliant
idea that they had was what about if we
were to take known illegal galactic your
own I dragged mints and put a probe on
it let's say like Alexa fluor 488 and
then incubate cells where the pectin was
just being secreted and as it was the
esterified
it would match up with these external
the gold black your own eyes that have
alexa fluor 48 and these conjugates have
been very very helpful as well and just
this past year in the plant kernel you
also have had a nice sort of screening
of many different plants that use this
and this is where you get these
beautiful images I mean wonderful new
probes that are coming out all right so
that's the the pectin component of the
wall the inner wall layer is made of
cellulose so once again here's the outer
wall the inner layer has cellulose in it
this is a co label of Calca floor with
the antibody [ __ ] 5 and you could see
the cellulose on the inside another
probe that we have been using that's
just come out recently is a carbohydrate
binding module that goes after
crystalline cellulose but researchers in
Portugal had an ingenious idea and what
they've done is they've hooked AFP on it
and therefore you could pick up
cellulose microfibrils that are found in
the wall we can then use CBM
carbohydrate binding modules of PFP to
label the cellulose and here's the
pectin on the outside so the inner wall
layer consists of cellulose and
different orientations of cellulose
microfibrils
okay so cellulose is the load-bearing
component of the cell okay it is the
thing that's holding the wall together
not the pectins I really have not really
certain clue as to what the lattice the
pectin lattice is actually doing
probably something to do with adhesion
but when you do some simple experiments
like you use a microtubule oh I'm
inhibitor like a p.m. you get rid of the
cortical microtubules that are found in
the cell center and you weaken you cause
the cellulose wall to be thinner because
microtubules are controlling the
deposition of cellulose and then you get
turgor pressure calling these causing
these swellings or what about treating
your cells in an e beat a EDTA a key
later solution we could get rid of the
pectin this is Jim five label and the
cell could be put back in a culture and
ultimately it will produce more pectin
but for several days it doesn't need it
who knows or you can put the cells in
spectate lice and you could literally
strip off the outer layer fluorescent
image with Kym five here's your SEM
here's your TM and this is a cell that's
labeled with Jim five not a speck of the
homo galaki Ronan put the cell in the
culture it's as happy as can be in in a
couple of days it will produce more home
look like your own aunt how does the
wall expand well the wall expands from
the center on out
so hoops sorry about that alright so
I'll make this a little bit easier so
the center of the cell where the nucleus
is that is called the isthmus and this
is the zone where new wall materials are
produced and it pushes old wall material
out so basically the cell is expanding
in that direction this cartoon if you
maybe a little better idea of what's
going on this zone right over here would
be new wall gets more and more walls
pushing the old wall out and then
ultimately you get cell division with
daughter cells and very very simple I
mean black Edurne Desmond's have that
symmetry but it's a very easy thing
any of the case to understand how
expansion occurs and the central zone is
known as the isthmus all right so what
we have done is we have looked at dis
Mazzone expansion what happens is that
you have pectins okay Houma collect your
own ends that are methyl is terrified
that are secreted here in this central
zone this is miss then they are Dias
terrified by pectin methyl ester ace and
now we go to Jim 5 and this is where
this would be located this is Jim 7
label here the esterified pectin this
dark zone over here is where this would
be found and then over on either side
you have the pectin that has become the
esterified that picked up calcium so the
pectin is now being pushed to the
outside and the cellulose as well and
you get this bipolar displacement and
here's an Fe SEM view showing we believe
some of the the pectin Homa collect your
own M fibrils before they have complex
calcium in form this particular lattice
right cellulose is the first polymer
that is produced in this expansion zone
the microfibrils are deposited in
perpendicular direction to the direction
of expansion and are associated with the
cortical band of microtubules so here is
just a simple second here's the
cellulose here in the s Mazzone and
here's the lattice that's being formed
here's a glancing section where you can
see the cellulose microfibrils they're
in this orientation and cell expansion
bella is going in this horizontal
direction if you look at the cell just
underneath the plasma membrane you have
the series of cortical microtubules that
are probably directing the way in which
cellulose is deposited so any loss of
course was made by sesay complexes on
the plasma membrane and here's the court
of Cole microtubule band as well
okay so shortly after the cellulose is
produced the the RG one is deposited
this is with the antibody in row are you
one that I showed you before and then
and we start to see the lattice that
starts to form and starts pushing out
the cold cell wall material all right
one other thing the cell wall has some
sticky business and a sticky business is
adhesion if you take cells and you place
them on a substrate and on that
substrate you let them sit for a while
they'll come together and they will
stick and they will at fixed to a
substrate very very firmly and we were
interested in what this sticky stuff
might be so you could take soaps sorry
you could take some beads poly sere
beads and put them around the cell
that's just been washed in within a
matter of seconds there's something
sticky on the outside surface so what's
responsible for this thick eNOS that
allows the cell to adhere to some kind
of a substrate well we can use a
monoclonal antibody known as Jim 13
which is probably the gold standard for
identifying Arab no galactic proteins in
plants and what we find is that on the
outer surface of the wall you get a very
distinct label the Jim 13 labeling is on
the outer surface of the wall we can do
the Co labeling with Kalpa floor or with
two on antibodies of pectin antibody and
this is probably the better picture to
see here is the Jim 13 in red and over
here in green is the gym five so it's
found on the outside of the pectin
lattice the Jim 13 material also adheres
to substrates and it leaves a footprint
here's a cell that was placed on a
coverslip okay and we just left there
just for a few minutes and we push the
cell off rolled it off here's the
footprint and you can see where some of
the Jim 13 label came on so it appears
to be the glue all right
Western analysis what we have found
amusing Jim 13 we find that we have a
couple of high molecular weight bands
here in cell wall fractions and also we
find it in the EPS fraction and we're
not exactly sure what this means here
but it probably means some of the
adhesive material has been sloth off
this is in addition to that EPS
that gel that is produced by on the
organism and then just real quickly if
we look at the TEM here's that pectin
lattice and here's the fibrils a that
our Jim 13 positive and here's sort of a
an overview it forms sort of like a
little reticulated network here on the
outside immuno gold labeling here's kim
13 it corresponds to what we saw with
immunofluorescence so there appears to
be a fiber layer of black damp proteins
that are found on the outside and may be
important in sticking the outer v roller
layer is not attached to the home of
galacto ronan we could get rid of the
home little actor Onan and these five
rolls will still appear they go into the
inner part of the wall all right so the
the pectin lattice is for at least part
of this this is kind of a story that's
still being told you know don't know
what it is here we could strip off the
outer home of the lackey ronan and there
are the five rolls so they're very
resistant and the outer filer layer is
laid down at the Isthmus very early on
here's a the isthmus zone in an
expanding wall and already we see that
there are these ADP like fibrils that
were calling a mage illegal spot like
fibrils so the sticky material is very
very significant and we find it in a lot
of organisms
now something Trevor suggested back last
year was why do we not take a look and
see what happens if we incubate the
cells with something like phospholipid
see to see if there might be an anchor
that's found in the plasma membrane
perhaps you have these aging peas going
through the wall and anchoring in the
plasma membrane well to make a long
story short here's our control cell here
is phospholipase C treated cells we lose
most of the AG P and here's a TM image
and this is a zone where during
phospholipase treating treatment we've
those particular fibrils so this
suggests that a GPS and a GP like
molecules are responsible for adhesion
but I just wanna in this particular part
by just saying is that we're just
learning about a GPS in terabytes and it
may been very important in the evolution
of land plants sticky material that if
we look at things like spirogyra and we
wound spirogyra filaments they formed
these rhizoids and then if you label
them with gym 13 the only time you ever
see arrive no galactic proteins is in
the wound response or here in that
organism chloric ibis that I mentioned
the oddball of the Kara fights its
sheath which allows it to stick the
substrates is made of a GP so a GP may
be the superglue of Kara fights and may
have been very very important in
evolution so finally what I like to just
do is just tell you some just real good
things about membrane trafficking in the
like Pentium and question is is how does
a plant cell expands well we should know
that it expands basically because of two
reasons
the force that's causing expansion is
that of internal turgor pressure and the
cell wall and modifications of the cell
wall to causing slippage of the
cellulose microfibrils allows for
controlled expansion and in the
world.the plants we have diffusive polar
growth mechanisms where we have wall
polymers added two different possibly
evenly distributed areas in the wall and
then you get sort of a more even
expansion of the wall and on the
opposite end of that spectrum you get
polar growth and that's where wall
synthesis like in the palm tube or a
root here is concentrated here at the
tip alright so in pentium to finish the
story up right Pentium expansion
dynamics I want to leave you with this
this organism is a lean a polysaccharide
producing machine I mean this organism
like many of the Desmond's
is perfect organism for study in secret
dynamics in plant cells right and one
thing that I just want to reiterate is
that it's here in this zone right over
here right in the Isthmus where we have
the wall materials produced at first and
being secreted at first cell wall
expansion requires a very distinct
cytoskeletal network and this is kind of
an intriguing thing that we were
studying a couple years ago so if you do
immuno labeling of the particle micro
tubular on network infinium what you
find in a normal cell before expansion
is you find a band of microtubules
cortical microtubules then what happens
is before expansion you get satellite
bands appearing from the mother strand
and they start to move away from the
mother strand on as the cell starts to
expand great alright then in this
picture over here you can see they're
starting to move away and they're going
to mark the zone where are the Isthmus
is in the daughter cell cell has even
defined it yet
so it's in many ways pretending it's
kind of a pre pre phobic prophase fan
it's predicting the plane of cell
division numb to division cycles away
right it's it's identifying where the
Isthmus is going to be in the daughter
cells well what happens is when the cell
goes into cell division we lose this
cortical microtubule band is probably
contributing to the spindle and also to
the sign of kinetic device and then if
you look at the daughter cells here is
okay was over here on this mother cell
here's one of the daughter cells and it
has this particular band all right so
these cortical micro tubular bands were
kind of a surprise to us and just real
quick they had multiple functions they
marked a plaintive division there are
source of microtubules for the spindle
and the psychokinetic apparatus probably
direct cellulose in --this is involved
in nuclear movement which certainly we
could talk about a unique way of moving
the nucleus in Desmond's
right also we have cortical actin bands
that are very
did all this here's wrote me phalloidin
labeling of pen IAM and these ropes
these cables of actin are found in the
cell and at the time of expansion what
will happen is you get these bands yet
line up with those cortical microtubule
bands and it's very likely that this
cytoskeleton network excuse me decide on
modal network is interfacing with the
cytoskeletal network for the accurate
delivery of secretory materials all
right but the key thing here is the
secretory apparatus opinion is truly
amazing and what i want to just point
out to you is that here's pentium and
here's of chloroplasts and these dark
zones over here are valleys of cytoplasm
you do not have big vacuoles in this
organism there vacuoles but they're
small and meandering it is in these
little zones over here
that you have the cytoplasm and that's
where the funds things start so here's
just a simple longitudinal section of
pentium and we went on a hunt to see how
many Golgi bodies a single cell has and
so this is just one portion of the cell
and we think there's between 125 and 150
Golgi bodies alright so then what we
take a look at is what does Pentium um
have that's different than higher plants
alright so as we get close to this this
is my performance art part of the
presentation so in higher plants I'm a
Golgi body and Golgi bodies in a rounded
axis for example moving around they're
moving around and all of a sudden they
need to secrete something over there so
then you come in this is ER of course if
you didn't know that they'll dock in and
then the Golgi starts shooting things
out they're stationary rather what they
have over here is they produce a series
of vesicles that get caught up on that
actin network here on the periphery of
the cell they always have a ready supply
of secretory vesicles for EPS for a wall
material and that's the stuff that
Motul so whenever they need that
material some kind of signal cascade
probably occurs and let's get those
vesicles to that zone and let's start
secreting this is true for other
Desmond's as well so very different
Golgi bodies are not mobile they are
stuck in the cytoplasm and just real
quick that the Golgi bodies are quite
unique
lots of cisterna they have a trans-golgi
network but for you people who are cell
biologists let me just point out I've
never seen a secretory vesicle
associated with a tgn in pentium and
that's not what you find in on land
plants so there are some differences
each Golgi body can produce both wall
materials and the EPS ETS secretion is
can be focused here's a cell that was
placed on a substrate and we fixed it
for electron microscopy we are looking
at the zone where EPS was being produced
there's the picture of it oh sorry about
this guys and here's the substrate down
here and what we see in this zone where
the cell is attached we have these
vesicles that pull and release the EPS
so there obviously are some interesting
signals and wall expansion zone we have
wall vesicles that will come up and
contribute to pectins into whatever else
we also think we've identified a group
of small vesicles probably containing
Sesay that are going to come into this
particular zone as well we don't know
for certain but that's an ongoing
project and the last thing is that there
is an endo siddik pathway in pentium in
all Desmond's and it's really really
quite the state and we can use things
like the FM guys 464 143 and the dye is
immediately take it up it gets on the
cytoplasmic streaming network and then
it they kind of come together in fuse in
a very distinct vacuolar network okay
some of these vacuoles are autophagy
they've got membranes in them but a very
unique vacuolar system that's involved
in endocytosis
so with that let me just say that if
you're interested in secretory dynamics
in plants for the production of cell
walls or whatever this is an organism
that I want us to sell you on it for
only 995 I'll give you a know I mean
it's a I think has tremendous potential
and we'll forget this particular picture
and let me finish up by saying that
there are many many different projects
that we're looking into we're looking
into stress in secretory we're looking
at the way in which the cytoskeleton and
a membrane trafficking network org and I
won't bore you with this but I like to
finish up and say thank you to this I've
ever had in my life and the National
Science Foundation yeah yes yeah well I
the details of because I don't know the
details of it but obviously there's
tremendous about a photosynthate that is
directed into yes and if you grow these
things in culture under high light
conditions the amount of EPs for example
over let's say a 24-hour period will
increase three times
so this EPS means something to them and
they put a lot of photosynthetic
material into it it's a great question
your question have I've always had about
organisms like this and other parasites
that are found for example in these
ephemeral pools is you'll see these
things bloom and they'll produce this
incredible amount of EPs it's like green
jello and then about a week here it's
gone I mean the Eco dynamics with this
and what that's being used for in the
carbon cycle of that ecosystem
nobody knows yes there is no Golgi
bodies there okay and for most the time
before expansion is its you had the
nucleus and then you have cytoplasm
around the nucleus and you could just
see the typical vesicles but it's know
very little ER and no Golgi bodies
they're in the lobes of cytoplasmic
lobes of that are defined by the
chloroplasts yeah so the active network
goes all the way through so if you're
looking at for example vesicles you want
to see what happens it just doesn't stop
at the Isthmus they will go around and
then somewhere during the expansion
obviously pulls a ball precursor
containing vesicles are pulled off into
the Isthmus or for the expansion process
well the only thing I could tell you is
what Charles
at the University of Maryland on has
reported and his point is it's just it's
been a evolutionary reduction process it
can't really you know really explain it
and if very well could be because you
know they've had four hundred and fifty
million years as well too
yeah yeah I would assume that there is a
lot on both the point I was trying to
make is that you know as far as looking
for basic sub cellular dynamics you know
this but I agree with you I mean it's a
really fascinating story right now about
the phylogeny of late divergent era
fights it's a story that I think is
going to be we're going to learn a lot
when we get more genomes out there this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu